Newton's third law states
that forces always come
in equal and opposite pairs.
One way we can write that is
if you imagine two objects,
object one and object two, the
force exerted by object one
on object two is equal and
opposite to the force exerted
by object two on object one.
This makes explicit that
real forces always arise
from a physical interaction.
For any force in a
problem, you should always
be able to identify the other
member of the interaction pair.
Newton's third law
is the most subtle
and sometimes the most confusing
of his three laws of motion
so I'd like to do an
example that will help
clarify how to think about it.
So I'm going to pick a
very extreme example.
Let's imagine the collision
between a marble moving
this way and a train
moving that way.
And so we'll say that
the mass of the train--
I'll write that
as "m sub train"--
and the mass of the
marble is m sub marble.
And obviously, the
mass of the train
is much larger-- I'm
going to write that
as several greater-than
signs-- much, much larger
than the mass of the marble.
And so the question I want to
consider is, at the instant
that these two objects collide,
which experiences the greater
force?
So think about that
yourself for a moment.
In terms of outcomes,
clearly, the marble
will be smashed by the train
whereas the train will not
be noticeably affected
by the marble.
So your intuition
might therefore
suggest that it's the marble
that feels the greater force.
But that's incorrect because
Newton's third law tells us
that forces come in
equal and opposite pairs.
And what that tells
us is that each object
will exert an equal
but oppositely directed
force on the other.
Now I chose a very
extreme example
to capture your attention.
But that might seem
like a surprising result
but Newton's third law tells us
that the forces on each object
are going to be
equal and opposite.
But just because
the forces are equal
doesn't mean that the
motion will be equal.
The accelerations
of the two objects
are vastly different because
of their different masses.
And the accelerations
and the forces
are related by Newton's
second law, F equals m a.
So if I write that in
terms of the acceleration,
the acceleration of
the marble, "a marble,"
is equal to the force divided
by the mass of the marble
whereas the acceleration
of the train
is equal to-- so since I
wrote "F" for the force acting
on a marble, I'm going to write
minus F for the force acting
on the train.
So that's minus F divided
by the mass of the train.
And so if I want to look
at the ratio, how big is
the acceleration of
the marble divided
by the acceleration
of the train?
And let's take the absolute
value so we're just
talking about magnitudes here.
That's going to be equal to
the mass of the train divided
by the mass of the marble.
But the mass of the
train is much, much,
much larger than the
mass of the marble
so the right-hand side here
is a very, very big number.
And that tells us that
relative to the acceleration
of the train, the
acceleration of the marble
is going to be enormous.
Even though the force
experienced by each object
is identical, because of
their different masses,
their accelerations
will be very different.
So that gives us
an example of what
we mean by Newton's third law,
in terms of the interaction
pair and equal and
opposite forces acting.
I want to reiterate that
for any force in a problem,
you should always be able
to identify the other member
of the interaction pair.
So forces always come in pairs.
It's important to keep in mind
that these force pairs don't
both act on the same object.
They never act on
the same object.
The interaction
pair always involves
a pair of objects,
two different objects.
And let me just make that
explicit with an example.
The example I'll consider
is, imagine a person standing
on the ground.
What are the forces
acting on this person?
I'll draw the force
diagram here, say.
There's gravity,
mg, acting downwards
and there's a normal force
upward exerted by the ground.
And those two balance to give
a net force of zero, which
is why the person is
standing on the ground
and not sinking down into
the ground, for example.
Now, you might look at
gravity and the normal force
and wonder if those are
an interaction pair.
And they're not because notice
that these two forces are both
acting on the same
object, the person.
The interaction
pair always comes
from realizing what is exerting
the force on the object.
So let's look at each
of these in turn.
Gravity is exerted by the Earth.
So if the Earth-- and this
means really the entire Earth--
exerts a force mg on the
person, Newton's third law
tells us that the person
exerts a gravitational force
on the entire Earth
of mg upwards.
Now, that might seem
remarkable to you
if you're just standing
around on the floor
that you are exerting
a gravitational force
on the planet but you are.
However, this is like
the example we just
talked about a moment ago.
The masses are
extremely different
even though the
forces are the same.
So the acceleration of the
Earth due to this person's mass
is negligible because
the Earth is so much more
massive than the person.
But Newton's third law
tells us that there
is a tiny acceleration on
the Earth due to the person.
That is the third
law pair for gravity.
mg downward exerted by
the Earth on the person
is paired with mg upward on the
Earth exerted by the person.
Now, for the normal force
acting on the person,
that force is exerted
by the ground.
So the ground exerts an
upward force N on the person.
Newton's third law
tells us that that
means that the person must
exert a downward force
N on the ground.
That is the interaction
pair for Newton's third law
for the normal force.